welcome back to the Rich Eisen show I
turn to my right and I see a member of
the Bleacher Report's family the synergy
is so strong you can me just feel it in
this room right now all over the place
Ron BR live.com and Taylor rooks take it
there premiered last night on the
Bleacher Report's social networks
YouTube and bleacher report.com good to
see you Taylor rooks energy as a matter
of fact you're dressed in a blue suit
just it's similar to the color scheme of
the Rich Eisen show I don't know if you
did that on purpose I did say that I did
well done it's all about it's all part
of the branding all on the brain
Congrats on your show thank you so much
I'm thrilled I'm happy with how it's
been going
okay Jimmy Butler was first up last
night and he's no Wallflower
Jimmy Butler he'll tell you what I mean
it's interesting he said on your show
that he almost quit basketball in
college yeah did that surprise you from
him it did because I actually didn't
think that when I asked him the status
that he's been that he would give me a
moment because a lot of the times people
just don't really want to open up and
give you that time but he talked a lot
about therapy and how he thought
basketball wasn't for him and he didn't
know what it was like to be away from
home and that vulnerability you don't
get to see a lot of time with athlete so
I was very appreciative that he decided
to really talk about he's got to know
what the name of the title of the show
is exactly I'm gonna ask you went there
yeah you took it there I did you know
and and and he is do you think based on
your conversation with him do you think
he's gonna be a Philadelphia 76er for a
long time what are your thoughts on that
this isn't even just like based off of
our conversation just when I think about
where I think III don't think that he's
gonna be a sixer not because of anything
he said but just what it seems like
Jimmy once out of life does he want does
he want to be a Clippard Jimmy or do you
want to be and as cliche as this sounds
like he just wants happiness and
happiness to him as just being around
his friends and like where they want to
be like when he's deciding where to go
they're genuinely going to sit at a
table he's gonna say the different teams
I want him and it's gonna be like where
do you guys want to live that's
seriously how he's going to make that
decision
it's like we're all everybody that lives
with him wants to be the happiest dad I
don't know where that is and I
stem-like what does happy to select for
you then and he specifically said it's
where my friends well it's definitely
not Minnesota yeah it's just interesting
that you you bring this up in that
regard and that he did as well it's just
fine I don't know it just seems more and
more difficult to determine what an
athlete does consider making him or her
happy yeah certainly in the NFL we just
saw Antonio Brown and Pittsburgh were
clearly he's also known league wide as
the best wide receiver and he was
talking about disrespect and a lot of
people view that as he didn't get any
more guaranteed dollars from the
Steelers on the table that made him
unhappy and now he's very happy in
Oakland Calif yeah another one is Odell
Beckham as well unhappy here that his
statements in his first press conference
with Cleveland just landed with me
knowing that the Giants would have
killed to have heard that out of his
mouth when he was here in New York City
for sure the thing about Odell though
and I and I have always kind of said
this is it just reached a point where
Odell couldn't be a giant any longer and
I think that he was not that he was
necessarily happy to be willing to
Cleveland but he was happy to have a
clean slate at a place where he felt
like he was gonna have new management
and a new teammates and just be in a
place where he felt maybe more
comfortable he could be himself why is
that I mean again you you covered
New York sports for SNY before joining
bleach report you've interviewed Odell
you know him what why could not why
could it not work in New York City for
Odell in some ways I just think people
decided who Odell was and when people
decide who you're going to be it's it's
very hard to get out of that box so if
everyone thinks it like Hotel is a diva
that always wants attention and is it
always like running around the field and
like being a listen extra human being he
could go five games and not do that but
since he already did it once he's going
to be that to you forever and especially
in New York it's very hard to get out of
the perception that anybody has for you
so he can go to Cleveland and now he's
Cleveland Odell and he's no longer in
New York hotel and I I think that it was
the best thing and I just hope that he
gets to Cleveland and he goes off and he
ends up
this best wide receiver that we all
think that he is but I think has been
really challenging for him to know that
some people don't see him is that based
on things that happened surrounding the
game if that makes sense it does
although you just wish you know
obviously for Giants fans who adored
number thirteen and for people who got
to meet him out and about in the
community here yeah metropolitan area I
know that whoever put in his mind
whatever box he was put in that he
couldn't get out of it granted the New
York media is unlike anything I have
ever experienced
I mean people would always say that but
then when I moved here it's like if you
do one thing
it's everywhere and when Odell did do
certain things sometimes like yeah
exactly 60 forever and it was kind of
blown upwards we think it's funny it
became this thing of like look at Odell
having his antics on the sidelines and
in New York it's just it'll you cheer
like one of the people that I have
coming up this season on the show it's a
qualm Barkley and we talked about that
he's like I feel very fortunate that I
don't have any negative you know
articles about me right now but he's
like it's bound to happen in New York
one day there's gonna be something bad
about me something bad will happen and
I'm gonna have to deal with that and I
think that's what athletes think all the
time when they come to the big city I
could not imagine one bad thing about
stand-up dude I have nothing but a man
crush on sacrum he knows that I know you
told them did I tell ya you told them
that yeah right now at the Super Bowl
you know I mean just I and I think to
Taylor Brooks here on the Rich Eisen
show take it there on the entire
bleacher report platforms social YouTube
and calm you're on the Rich Eisen show
is that I you just bringing I guess
everything that we're talking about
right here
so you've got Antonio Brown and Odell
Beckham in these spots where they happen
only their entire career and they feel
like maybe they've been put in a box use
your phrase yeah and they are feeling
like they need a change or deep down
they feel like a change is needed and
part of what's being brought on to a two
is you've got two young guys
who don't have that so-called baggage or
box and juju Smith Schuster and steak
Wan cereal and management are sitting
there going okay so this is what
drama-free generational talent looks
like and let's go there even though it
might cause a huge problem with our
fanbase to just send these elite people
packing for sure and and that's what I
think is really interesting just also
with the way that we view athletes in
general I always think about when Saint
Quan was about to be drafted and we
would always talk about Baker Mayfield
to write and it was always like some
people almost made State Kwan like the
anti Baker like bakers in your face he's
talking on the time he knows how good he
is but say Kahn was this person he was
good but was humble and never really
talked about it but I I always wonder
why we prefer one of those a Vidya over
the other like I don't I don't get
what's wrong with being out there and
knowing that you're really really good
and talking about it and having this
personality that is also lasting off of
the field and I think that for some
management they like to feel like
football is your life and it's only a
thing that you do and we're not gonna
know anything else about you but I
prefer like that other person well the
thing that drives me nuts every year at
the combine is we hear about somebody
who's some kid I forget his name right
now to be honest with you but I think
you've played for a Notre Dame and he's
got he he's a brilliant kid reads a lot
reads magazines is into politics is into
a lot of things yeah and you're
wondering about his commitment to
football and it's just like come on yeah
like there's more like I know we're
talking about the three F's faith family
and football Jerry Tillery our our or my
producer Evan just came in chimed in
from LA BC yeah I mean I know about the
three EPs Faith Family football I get it
but there's more to life and that's what
I prefer to have somebody who is more
than just about the sport but then again
I'm not in a locker room with these guys
I'm not also paying the millions of
dollars and I don't have that tunnel
vision yeah that's
step on me on that very rarely like do
you hear the teammates calling the other
teammate a distraction it's always
people that aren't in the locker room
like everyone said Odell is a
distraction but everyone on the team's
like I love playing with oh did we make
that up I kind of like we're bringing
this whole full circle is that yeah no I
I did not hear that he was a distraction
in the locker but I also just heard it
was just a constant grind with him yeah
and I don't know what that means I don't
know what that means and then I hear you
say that you you know he feel he felt
like he was in viewed in a certain way
that he could never escape here in New
York and I'm just wondering if if they
had won that one playoff game after the
boat trip in in green the boat trip
might be the box that we're talking
about here okay and then if they had won
that playoff game in Green Bay yes he
would still be he would still be a New
York giant yeah yeah but that's the
thing winning cures everything and I
don't know if he would have been judged
so harshly if they were also going to
the playoffs winning the playoff game
like but that's not what happened and so
we'll never really know Taylor rooks
here in the Rich Eisen show uh also you
sit down with Damian Lillard who I I
love him too yeah he gets no run zero
run he gets none and we talked about why
why is that I mean he attributes a lot
of it to the fact that he plays in
Portland but I don't want to give too
into the episode away but the thing that
is really sticks out to me about
Damian's episode is him talking about
what loyalty means to him and why it's
so important to him to stay in Portland
and how it has nothing to do with like
the city of Portland even like the
management it's the teammate it's the
people that he's around he was like
people always say that I'm just really
loyal player and this real guy but I
just want to stick up for the people
that have always stick tup for me and he
gets really introspective about just how
being an Oakland made him that way and
things that he saw growing up and how he
views the world differently than most
NBA players because of how he was raised
he is he's really really good but he's
certainly underappreciated I remember I
interviewed Dwyane Wade once
and he said the most underappreciated
players in the league where Damian
Lillard and CJ McCollum and I think he's
right about that who are the guys or
ladies that you want a book on your show
that you haven't yet
I love Serena Williams I mean everyone
loves Serena right like that's my dream
interview is there any boy I just I love
everything that she embodies like she
truly is the greatest and that's someone
else I think sometimes he tried to put
in a box we call her the greatest female
athlete or one of the greatest athletes
but like she is the greatest of so many
things she excels at so many different
things whether it's being a tennis
player being a wife being a mother like
she takes that mantra of being great to
everything in her life and I love
obviously her her HBO show that she did
but it always sticks out to me she's
like on the treadmill and she is talking
to her trainer Patrick and she was
having a rough training day and he gets
he's talking her and he goes tomorrow
you give your all she said I give my all
every day and he said yeah but I'm not
talking about the present I'm talking
about tomorrow and then she just goes on
to say like it doesn't really matter if
I was good yesterday or the day before
like it only matters if I'm also good
tomorrow and I just always think about
that she just really uses that lesson
through everything in her life and she's
just the perfect role model for everyone
well I mean and certainly with what her
life is today I remember you know being
on SportsCenter when she started yeah
and and it was all about her sister and
then it was like well oh that's Venus
has a younger sister huh okay
let's see what she can do because she
can't be Venus I mean Venus Williams was
Venus will yeah and that's how Serena
was born into the sports world mm-hmm
and now what she has become she's
eclipsed to everybody really is
remarkable they had to come to start
from that that was basically what she
was an afterthought because it was about
Venus and Richard Williams and then
though the whole concept was oh by the
way there's another one to come through
yeah in the same way that we talk about
the Manning brothers you know and what
she's been able to do is just
unbelievable for sure and I just really
people have such like a personal and
emotional connection to Serena that like
makes you appreciate her is you deceive
know her obviously you don't but I watch
her and
sometimes I want to cry right just the
passion that she shows like when she's
playing tennis is really moving to me so
one day I'll interview Serena okay
that'll be good and we'll look forward
to seeing that again on take it there
with Taylor rooks on the bleacher report
platforms plural bleacher report.com
social and YouTube great to see you here
we'll have you Nora Lawson oh I
definitely will let you know the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience